Salut ! Aujourd'hui j'ai un invité sur la chaîne du MentalVlog
Et cet invité c'est ...
C'est qui ?!
C'est moi !
C'est un plaisir en tant que magicien de rencontrer un mentaliste.
Ouais c'est ça. Armand, il est magicien
T'as une chaîne depuis combien de temps, Armand ?
C'est ça. Ouhlàà, alors ma chaîne ...
J'ai mon compte Youtube depuis à peu près 2009, je crois.
Il est hyper vieux !
Ouais ouais, c'est très très vieux.
Je fais venir Armand à la maison.Déjà ça fait longtemps qu'on se connaît, on voulait faire une vidéo ensemble.
Mais, on a cherché longtemps.
Tu m'avais même envoyé des super propositions.
Et je crois qu'au final, le plus intéressant, c'est de faire comme on avait fait avec Raj  AutoDisciple ...
... pour le "yes man" et tout ça
C'est de venir discuter avec TOI !
Des tours de magie, des beaux tours de magie, si on veut en voir, il suffit de cliquer là.
Ça vous emmène directement sur la chaîne d'Armand.
Tu vois ce que je veux dire ?
- Voilà !
Ils sont faits, ils sont faits donc allez les voir !
Ils sont super cool.
Ce dont j'aimerais parler, c'est justement de toi, de ton point de vue de magicien.
Je sais que le "truc" n'est qu'une toute petite partie de ton tour.
Alors en tout cas je pense ...
Ah bon ? Non pas du tout ! Tout est basé là-dessus mec.
Au-delà du truc, il y a quelque chose qui est très important, qui est même primordial quand tu présentes un tour de magie
C'est l'histoire que tu vas raconter derrière.
Et ça, en général, j'essaye de toujours de raconter une histoire derrière un tour de magie.
Par exemple, la vidéo qui marche le mieux sur ma chaîne, c'est celle où j'embrasse des filles.
Et l'histoire là-dedans, c'est que t'as une histoire un peu romantique.
Parce que c'est un tour de magie qui fait que tu vas pouvoir embrasser une fille.
Ça donne un petit côté féerique au tour.
L'effet où les cartes vont s'échanger ...
derrière ça, je rajoute le fait que la fille signe sa carte, le fait que je signe moi-même la carte.
Pour les mettre dans nos bouches, qu'on s'embrasse et là ça s'échange.
Je crée une vraie mise en scène avec une vraie petite histoire
Au cinéma, on appelle ça un enjeu en fait.
C'est-à-dire que là, il y a un enjeu, tu voulais embrasser la fille, tu vois, au final.
Donc s'il y a un enjeu, il y a une espèce de stress de notre côté pour savoir s'il va y arriver ou pas.
Parce que t'aurais pu faire la même chose avec les cartes posées dans les mains.
Et c'est ce que je fais d'ailleurs très souvent !
Ça me permet de voir justement les réactions.
Et je peux t'assurer que la réaction quand t'embrasse la fille à qui tu fais le tour de magie, elle est beaucoup plus spectaculaire !
Et petite parenthèse parce qu'on ne sait jamais, il n'a jamais forcé personne à l'embrasser !
A chaque fois, regardez la vidéo : c'est un truc cool et c'est respectueux envers les filles.
Comme il y a tellement de polémiques en ce moment, je préfère juste le préciser.
En général, j'en parle déjà avant avec la fille. Je lui propose.
Et puis tu la tiens pas comme ça !
Voilà ce qu'on dégage de la conversation :
Je vous fais le récap parce que ça va vous paraître plus clair.
Voilà, il y a la technique du magicien au départ
Il y a l'idée de base qui est de transposer deux cartes.
Après il y a le fait de choisir un angle hyper intéressant qui est sur toute l'histoire de la séduction etc.
qui donne un vrai enjeu en fait au tour.
Il y a le fait de rajouter en subtilité les signatures qui casse un chemin magique, ...
... une explication possible qui est des cartes en double, parce que ça les rend unique.
Là, on voit tout le travail qui se dégage, en fait.
- C'est ça !
C'est pas juste un magicien qui prend ses cartes, qui va dans la rue,  et qui bat ça, quoi.
L'impossibilité magique en elle-même ne suffit pas, après ça devient un casse-tête en fait.
Qu'est-ce que tu recommanderais à quelqu'un qui voudrait se mettre à la magie aujourd'hui ?
Les trois conseils d'Armand pour quelqu'un qui veut se mettre à la magie ?
Les trois conseils d'Armand ?
Je dois avouer, déjà, ne pas faire comme moi : ne pas lire beaucoup de livres.
Parce que j'avoue ne pas avoir lu beaucoup de livres en magie.
Et c'est vrai que les livres ... je commence à me prendre des livres un peu intéressants pour me plonger dedans.
Parce que, c'est vrai que des livres, c'est très utiles pour les magiciens.
Je pense que tu recommanderas la même chose.
TADAM !
J'ai vu ça juste avant, j'ai fait ouh làlà làlà làlà ! Qu'est-ce que c'est beau !
Donc voilà, il y a des livres très bons pour débuter dans la magie.
Je sais que j'ai beaucoup entendu parler des livres de Roberto Giobbi.
Je pense que tu connais.
- Oui, bien sûr !
Dai Vernon aussi.
Un autre conseil que je pourrais donner ...
C'est de passer des heures à s'entraîner, quoi.
Il y a bien un truc à faire quand tu veux te lancer dans la magie :
C'est de prendre des après-midi dans ta vie, et de prendre tes cartes et de recommencer des choses des centaines de fois.
Tu recommences de manipulations comme ça.
Moi, je faisais ça, beaucoup, quand j'étais devant la télé, tu sais.
En regardant la télé, tu peux faire ça en même temps.
Moi, si j'ai un conseil à ajouter c'est : faites rapidement des tours à des gens que vous ne connaissez pas
et pas à votre famille ou à vos meilleurs amis.
Parce qu'en fait, à ce moment-là tu prends le rôle d'un magicien. Mais eux, ils savent que t'es pas magicien !
Tu sais que c'était le troisième conseil que j'allais donner ?
- Ah oui ? C'est vrai ? Ah oui, c'est tellement ça !
Oui, ça marche pas, parce qu'ils te connaissent d'avant que tu fasses de la magie.
Et donc, à part vouloir t'embêter, commencer à tout fouiller, tout toucher, tout mélanger et te mettre des bâtons dans les roues, ça marche pas.
C'est exactement ça, quelqu'un que vous ne connaissez pas, il va être très ...
Allez dans la rue, c'est ça, c'est ce que je voulais dire.
Faut aller dans la rue et il faut dire "Bonjour, ça vous dérange si je vous montre un petit tour de magie comme ça ? ...
Je vous demande pas d'argent et tout, c'est juste pour le fun."
Et puis vous vous entraînez, vous trouvez des amis qui partagent la même passion.
Et puis tout simplement, vous allez vers des gens que vous ne connaissez pas, vous montrez des petits tours de cartes.
N'attendez pas le tour de ouf pour vous entraîner ou faire un tour.
Parce qu'en fait c'est vous qui êtes ouf, c'est ça le tour !
C'est comment vous allez amener votre tour qui va donner ce côté ouf au tour.
Je fais des tours de magie qui sont des tours des fois très banals.
Des tours que si un magicien me voit, il me fait "t'as pas le droit de faire ça, c'est tellement nul".
Des fois j'en fais en soirée et ce sont ces tours-là qui ont des fois la meilleure réaction.
Parce que tu viens déjà de prouver que t'étais un bon magicien.
Donc si tu fais un petit tour derrière qui peut paraître banal, selon la façon dont tu l'amènes, il peut être au final extraordinaire pour le spectateur.
Merci beaucoup Armand !
J'espère que cette discussion avec un vrai magicien en chair et en os qui a une chouette chaîne, vous a plu.
T'as dit que j'étais en chair et en os ?
Ah, c'est du plastique, mec !
- C'est aimanté !
- Je suis un robot
- Ah ouais, c'est aimanté !
Allez faire un tour sur la chaîne d'Armand, regardez les vidéos.
Puis, on se retrouvera là-bas parce qu'on a fait une petite vidéo aussi sur ma chaîne.
Il ment : on va la faire. Mais oui, c'est vrai !
Mais oui, oui, j'avais oublié qu'on la faisait dans la foulée !
Merci beaucoup d'avoir écouté cette conversation, merci Armand t'es passionnant.
Merci à toi de l'invitation.
Mais je t'en supplie !
Et puis vous n'oubliez surtout pas de vous abonner à la chaîne avant de partir puisque le MentalVlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an jusqu'au 31décembre.
Donc rendez-vous demain à 17h !
Jusqu'au 31 décembre ne loupez aucune de ses petites vidéos ! Il est là tous les jours.
Merci mon pote ! Ciao !